Samsung's Galaxy S 10 is going to be
announced at their unpacked event on
February 20th and there's recently been
a ton of leaks surrounding specs and
final design
we're expecting three different models
including the s10 Plus which is said to
be packing some pretty impressive
performance specs the question for a lot
of us is if the iPhone 10 S is still
gonna hold the crown for the fastest
smartphone available hit that like
button and we'll go through all the
recent s10 leaks and see it we should
expect on February 20th last year in
April
91 Mobile's leaked renders of the Galaxy
S 10 plus featuring a bezel is design
with a hole-punch dual lens selfie
camera on the front of the phone earlier
this year we also saw images of the
regular s10 model with a single lens
hole punch instead and we've seen
multiple leaked images that basically
confirm what the front will look like
there was also a rumor of the s10
featuring reverse wireless charging
which was almost confirmed by a leaked
legit looking render of the Samsung's
upcoming Galaxy buds sitting on top of
the s10 the Galaxy buds are meant to be
a direct rival to Apple's air pods and
yes we will definitely be doing a
comparison video between the two so
subscribe now so you don't miss out the
sn+ is set to feature a dual lens camera
in the front and a triple lens camera in
the back as seen by the seemingly
official leaked renders the cheaper s10
motto would keep the triple lens for
your camera but switched to a single
lens in the front both of those models
are set to support a fingerprint sensor
under the display the even cheaper s10
II may not support in display
fingerprints sensing tech and will
simply have a dual lens camera on the
back just like the note 9 now let's talk
about performance Geekbench for
benchmark scores from the Galaxy S 10
plus a snapdragon 855 processor have
been leaked featuring a 3413 single core
in 10,000 256 molten core scores the
equinox 98 xx powered model was also
leaked with scores of 4382 single core
and 9500 70 multi-core interestingly
those scores put the S 10 plus on par
with the iPhone 10 from 2017 the iPhone
10s Tennis Max and ten are completely
blow both processors out of the water
with a single core score of 4,795 in a
multi-core score of eleven thousand two
hundred sixty seven so from those leaks
the latest iPhones really don't have
to worry about since Samsung's 2019
smartphone will most likely pack these
underpowered processors on top of that
iPhones are usually better optimized for
performance and RAM management also
leaked with some antutu benchmark scores
with the s10 plus scoring 325 thousand
points still less than the iPhone 10's
is record holding 352 thousand points so
the iPhone doesn't really have anything
to worry about in terms of graphics
either Apple has been doing a great job
of increasing processor performance
every year for the last few years so
we're expecting future iPhones to hold a
performance crown as well back to
Samsung S 10 leaks Evan blast posted a
seemingly official image of the Galaxy S
ten lineup looking similar to a Galaxy
Note 9 except with the long and narrow
camera bump and the removal of the
fingerprint sensor FCC filings also show
that the Galaxy S 10 could be one of the
first devices to support Wi-Fi six which
has also been rumored for the 2019
iPhones so with all those leaks there's
no doubt that the Galaxy S 10 is going
to be a great lineup of phones packin
some new tech we're hoping to see in
future iPhones as well as far as
performance we expect the iPhone 10s to
outperform the new S 10 devices and will
be comparing everything from performance
to camera quality as soon as they get
released so make sure to subscribe for
that what are your thoughts on the
upcoming Galaxy S 10 let us know in the
comments section below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video